so once the scripting data has been
loaded we can now move forward with
loading our assets images maps etc now
typically you can load assets and
scripts at the same time but I've been
burned by that in HTML once or twice
injected JavaScript code can easily
suggest more assets to be loaded which
would require more kickoffs of acing
calls and tracks to follow as such for
sanity well mainly my receding hairline
we let Gritz scripting code come in
first define their systems and a set
needs and then kick off all the
subsequent asset loads afterwards in
grits instead of calling window alert
this is where we actually kick off phase
3 where we parse our texture Packer
Atlas definition and load the map
objects once that was done we can
actually let the user play the game by
turning off the UI and showing the
canvas elements once we've gone through
our three phases of loading the menu the
scripting data and then the assets
finally we can allow the user to get to
the screen and play the game it's only
through the combination of all of these
together do we ensure a nice easy
transition for the user they constantly
shows them a refreshing UI